the government is taking a unique
approach to control the record-breaking
population of wild horses there are an
estimated 88 thousand of them across
this country the American icons are
protected by a law passed by Congress
back in 1971 but too many wild mustangs
can lead to big problems like starving
horses Nicki batise who knows how to
ride a horse she's an equestrian take a
good look at her shows us a new effort
to help them find a home Nicki good
morning to you good morning Gail I am a
horse lover there are now 50,000
Mustangs and holding pens available for
adoption but the number of people taking
one home has had an all-time low in
recent years that's part of the reason
the Bureau of Land Management is now
offering to pay you $1,000 to adopt a
wild horse these two male Mustangs
aren't horsing around it's that time of
year breeding season breeding season
they're locked in a battle over the
females of the herd we met Gus War of
the Bureau of Land Management in Utah he
told us the rapid reproduction of wild
horses is creating a crisis we're
estimating there's 88 thousand wild
horses in America right now and how many
can the land sustain 27,000 galloping it
up to 30 miles per hour in the mountains
and plains of Utah these Mustangs
symbolize freedom freedom has its
consequences if they're not managed
those consequences can be over graze
land and starving horses that's why BLM
rounds up thousands of horses each year
but the humane society and wild horse
campaign told CBS News the roundups can
be dangerous
leaving some horses injured or dead or
they may be adopted and illegally sold
for slaughter war says BLM spends 50
million of it's 80 million dollar budget
on off range holding costs for the
Mustangs they gather we're almost
approaching $2,000 to hold a horse for
one year so BLM did some simple math
rather than pay $2,000 to care for a
Mustang for one year they'll pay $1,000
to someone willing to adopt and care for
Mustang over its lifetime do you worry
about people who say hey wait a second
I'm gonna go get one of those Mustangs
take a thousand bucks and take it to a
slaughterhouse you know we use it you
have to you have to say you've got to be
concerned about that so if an adopted
horse after a year is abused and you
hear about it you can't take it back so
if a horse is adopted and then it's
titled and we hear about us having an
abuse case we immediately reach out to
the local humane group we visited an
adoption in Livingston Texas $1,000 per
horse what a good incentive yeah we're
Rebekah Hirshman brought her 11 year old
granddaughter Abby you know Mustangs
don't let many people pet them isn't a
special horse to qualify adopters must
have enough space for a horse and no
history of animal abuse anybody else and
pen 6 well a completely wild horse and
$500 up front the other 500 comes one
year later it's beneficial but it's not
why we're here
I can see why they are doing it because
it gives point people to take a chance
on a wild horse
Deborah Cash and Michael Gelles are
taking home their very first Mustang
what are you looking for I look at their
eyes see if they make contact with you
Rebecca plans to spend her $1,000
payment on a trainer and horse supplies
upset with us because we're actually
bringing home money but when you see
this kind of human horse connection the
boys picture could attract the worst
picture it doesn't really seem the money
matters at all I just think it's about
finding in my home I feel like I'm
helping you know
the maximum number of wild horses you
can be paid to take is for BLM says
adoptions have gone up nearly 40 percent
since the thousand dollar incentive
began in March but the humane society
and American wild horse campaign say BLM
needs to focus its budget on fertility
control and that was my first time
seeing Mustangs in the flesh and they
are absolutely beautiful but in the
meantime those adoptions will go up more
after looking at this piece because you
know you're helping someone helping at
the horse and there's such majestic
creatures which you know very well and
they keep the teeth yes I grew up riding
and you were a nationally ranked ik
Western I was I did I did equestrian
show jumping my dad put me on a horse
and I was three it was history Missy
Mustangs I took him on the chute with oh
that's so great and more importantly you
rode a horse at your wedding I did I did
because sidesaddle because my dress was
so tight but yes they're very slow
horses way to not a wild horse so just
know that's Dolly we rented her because
the horse I ride is far too wild to have
a veil on its back I will say she's
downplaying guys because she was ranked
rode for 15 years was ranked nationally
number two my uncle actually adopted a
wild mustang trained it and it's a
beautiful horse loves it they're
wonderful endorsement and the two people
no story they're Mustangs are doing
really well very good Nicki thank you